admitted liar michael cohen has turned
on his former client donald trump in an
attempt to avoid prison time for his
crimes Cohen's lawyer Lanny Davis who
previously represented disbarred
criminal ex President Bill Clinton is
promising to take down the duly elected
president by helping the investigation
of Bob Muller the lawless special
counsel who was appointed to investigate
Russian meddling in 2016 and after two
years has found nothing other than Paul
man affords expensive taste in suits and
Michael Cohen's testimony that the
president who brags about sleeping with
porn stars may have slept with a porn
star what drama what television did you
expect anything less from the star of
reality TV we will analyze what the
Cohen plea really means how it's likely
to shake out legally and what it means
politically then as if that weren't
enough masterpiece cake shop Baker Jack
Phillips will stop by to discuss the
left's latest attempt to ruin his life
and destroy all of our religious freedom
the mainstream media have suddenly lost
interest in Molly Tibbets hmm wonder why
I wonder what changed mmm and finally
what Republicans can learn from Bill
Clinton on this day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can we fit anything else in today I feel
like there's not enough to talk about
did is anything happened in the last 24
hours
ah before we get to it there is so much
to get to and I got to tell you this is
one of these examples this is one of
these rare occasions where I agree with
Ben's analysis on this almost exactly
almost to a point I agree with his
analysis the difference being that I'm
fairly hopeful about how it's all going
to turn out but I'll explain my cause
for hope it's not just empty optimism
it's hope before we do that I've got
something else that should give you hope
and that is Lending Club got to thank
our great sponsors over at Lending Club
I really like Lending Club because for
decades credit cards have been telling
us buy it now pay for it later
with interest and despite your best
intentions that interest can get out of
control fast with a Lending Club you can
consolidate all of your debt pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment these credit card companies they
prey on people I've seen them do it
to friends family they will you know
they get you on the hook and then your
pain is insane interest rates don't do
that there is a much better way it's
very easy since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to
the bank no high interest credit cards
don't be foolish don't pay these giant
financial institutions way more than you
need to go to Lending Club com tell them
about yourself how much you want to
borrow if you're approved loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in just a few days L Lending
Club is the number one peer-to-peer
lending platform over thirty-five
billion billion with a B in loans issued
go to Lending Club comm slash Knolls KO
wles
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
$40,000 that is Lending Club comm slash
Knolls keno wles this could really
really help you out especially if you've
got some fixes to the house you need to
make some credit cards take it from me
do not do not pay these institutions
more than you need to Lending Club Khan
/ Knowles all loans made by web bank
member FDIC Equal Housing lender so what
do we got today we've got to the
Manafort verdict we've got Michael Cohen
within minutes Michael Cohen pleads
guilty the president under fire talks of
impeachment talks of putting off Brett
Cavanaugh's appointment to the court
talk
of a sex scandal taking down the
presidency Russell Crowe take it away
[Music]
[Applause]
that's why I'm here that is why I'm here
Russell are you not entertained is this
not what you signed up for when you
elected a reality TV star to become
president of course of course the way
this played out is unbelievable it's the
most dramatic presidency maybe ever
probably the most dramatic presidential
scene since the Ford theater we've got
it just consider the coincidence or the
Providence or who knows of a Paul
Manafort the campaign chairman for
former campaign chairman for Donald
Trump being found guilty of some charges
not all of his charges and then just
minutes later Michael Cohen the
president's former personal lawyer
pleads guilty to a certain crimes in
many cases the same crimes this there's
a lot to dissect here so I do want to I
want to get through all the specifics of
it they don't want to zoom out and
analyze what really will be the legal
and political effects of this because I
think sometimes when people are doing
analysis they get so lost in the weeds
they miss the bigger picture in the
weeds things don't look good for the
president in the bigger picture things
look very good for the president let's
get into the specifics first and then
we're everyone Jack Phillips so Paul
Manafort found guilty for what tax fraud
bank fraud in Virginia tax fraud and
bank fraud and what the prosecution kept
bringing up is all his nice suits and he
spent money frivolously and whatever
that's what they got him on tax fraud
and bank fraud minutes later Michael
Cohen what's he have found guilty of or
what does he admit guilt to tax fraud
bank fraud and campaign finance campaign
finance violations so two of the three
the exact same thing is Paul Manafort
tax fraud bank fraud now consider how
the media or treating these two guys
because they're they pled guilty to
basically the same things a Cohen or
they were found guilty and pled guilty
to basically the same things
Cohen actually pled guilty to another
crime which is campaign finance
violations how do they treat them Manta
Ford is a vicious horrible monster Cohen
all of a sudden people are getting a
strange
new respect for Michael : aren't they he
is free he is liberated he's gonna take
down the president no he's a crook he's
a crook if man affords a crook he's a
crook the difference is that the left
thinks that Cohen's testimony is going
to hurt Trump and Manta for it isn't
because mana for it took it like a man
and Michael Cohen is a dirty little rat
but we'll see we'll see what effect that
has so okay what did Cohen plead guilty
to Cohen pled guilty to tax fraud five
counts of it between 2012 and 2016
he made false statements to a bank
couple years ago unlawful campaign
contribution 2016 excessive campaign
contribution 2016 and that's what the
media are focusing on before we get into
the specifics too much on these guys I
do want to point out campaign finance
laws are mostly nonsense and
anti-constitutional these are laws that
say you can only contribute so much to a
candidate you can only spend money this
way you can only spend money that way
that those laws limit your political
speech they limit your freedom of speech
money is speech in politics the poster
that you're holding up in politics is a
political expression it's a
manifestation of your free speech and
that poster ain't free it costs money to
buy the markers and to buy the poster
board and to hold it up there it costs
money it costs time same thing with
campaign commercials
same thing with flyers same thing with a
website same thing with buses the same
thing with all of that this political
speech costs money because we live in a
real world and campaigns or tangible
things campaign finance laws mostly
nonsense
mostly arbitrary many of them have been
struck down by the Supreme Court the
mccain-feingold campaign finance law was
famously struck down in the Citizens
United decision and it doesn't make any
sense to have these laws because people
are gonna spend money on politics big
politics attracts big money surprisingly
not as much money as you would think
you'd consider you'd think these
presidential campaigns are so
consequential they'd cost 5 billions 7
billion dollars
no way far less than that but if you if
there's a limit let's say there's a
federal limit of $5,000 you can spend on
a candidate those candidates backers are
still going to spend money on them
they're just gonna find other ways to
spend it they're gonna spend it in super
PACs that's that's been one consequence
of recent years they're gonna spend it
in little back
anoles they're gonna they're gonna use
straw donations they're gonna have
family members donate money even though
it's really just their own personal
money this is how they got Dinesh
D'Souza
janeshia D'Souza had to go to the
slammer and hang out with murderers and
rapists because he funneled some money
to his friend Wendy long who was never
going to win a race anyway so I think
those laws in general are ridiculous
that said they are the laws so it's very
easy for prosecutors to get you on
campaign finance the laws are very
obscure and if you if you violate them
in any way that can really nail you now
what we know from Michael Cohen is that
there's no cooperation deal what does
that mean what does it mean he's not
apparently not cooperating with
investigators and prosecutors but then
lanny davis comes out that hit Michael
Cohen's lawyer and says he has info for
Muller and he really wants to give the
info from Muller here's lanny davis i
can tell you that mr. cohen has
knowledge on certain subjects that
should be of interest to the special
counsel and is more than happy to tell
the special counsel all that he knows
not just about the obvious possibility
of a conspiracy to collude and corrupt
the american democracy system in the
2016 election which the trump tower
meeting was all about but also knowledge
about the computer crime of hacking and
whether or not mr. trump knew ahead of
time about that crime and even cheered
it on and we know he publicly cheered it
on but did he also have private
information hold on there I'm sorry I'm
a little confused so he Lanny Davis is
saying we've got all this info mr.
Muller come on I know you want it we
have info we can answer the question did
Trump cheer on the hacking and the
Russians finding information from those
hacked servers did he cheer it on and
then Lanny Davis admits he said well
yeah I mean we know he did because he
did it publicly well so what do I need
you for what are you gonna give me yeah
this is the great thing about Donald
Trump
and this is actually what distinguishes
him from other politicians who have been
you know maybe a little fast and loose
with their mouths
fast and loose with other aspects of
their lives like Bill Clinton as an
example is Clinton would always kind of
pretend he would always try to be too
clever by half with Donald Trump he just
tells you he said yeah hey if you find
those Clinton emails Russia give them to
me I want to see him we all want to know
where they went
he's a he's sort of a guileless figure
in that way he's an honest broker in
that regard he this is what I want I'm a
straight talker I'm a straight shooter
and I speak like a New Yorker so there's
a little bit of a difference there and
look he's obviously begging right I mean
they're begging please give us some
special care please please we want to
help you out we want to help you out and
of course lanny davis has to spin all of
this right because we know that Michael
Cohen is a liar he's an admitted liar
that the events of yesterday show us
that he's a liar but he's got to spin it
and turn this guy who's basically a
dodgy kind of crooked New York lawyer
into this this Saint this martyr for the
truth here's Lanny talking about truth
to power but in one very important
respect Michael is relieved he's a good
man with a good heart that I discovered
but he's relieved and liberated is the
word I would say to your audience
because now he has no shadow hanging
over him the uncertainty is gone he has
stepped up to the line and he has
admitted what he did wrong but he is now
liberated to tell the truth everything
about Donald Trump that he knows that
led him to approach someone like me who
he knows politically doesn't share
anything with president Trump and from
this point on you're going to see
liberated Michael Cohen speaking truth
to power he's relieved and liberated is
that right we are living in such an
Orwellian time he's relieved and
liberated absent he's terrified for his
life he's terrified for his property and
for his family and his career in his
possessions and he's not speaking truth
to power he's the the power is this
bureaucracy the power is this constant
machine and campaign to undo the 2016
election and he got crushed by them
speaking truth to power are you kidding
me
he got crushed by the pollen
sized arm of the federal government
that's the that's what he's speaking
he's not liberated at all he's not not
liberated he's he's now their pasta ch
basically and and by the way this whole
thing so we've got two stories now
Michael Cohen is saying I'm according to
Lanny Davis Michael Cohen is saying you
know Michael Michael realizes that Trump
is a danger to the country he's finally
realized he's ready he it's his
patriotic duty to come out and stop the
Trump presidency
even though for the last two years he
said the Trump is great and he basically
watched over the Trump ascendants so
that's the one story and then the other
story is Michael Cohen is worried about
the feds crushing his family those are
the those are you can't have both you
can't have both of those stories those
are not you cannot hold them
simultaneously
either he's realized aw shucks it
doesn't matter what happens to me or my
family I'm gonna speak truth to power
and stop the Trump presidency or you
realize that that front presidency which
you helped to facilitate is now coming
under attack by even greater powers than
the President and you want to save
yourself and your family from being
crushed it's obviously the latter so he
doesn't think that he's getting a pardon
I guess that you know he I don't think
that the Michael Cohen is going to get a
pardon so now he's got to go into the
other direction and this is written this
this question of pardons is kind of
interesting because it shows you the
differing behavior of Paul Manafort and
Michael Cohen but listen to Lanny Davis
spin this stuff about a presidential
pardon here he is on NPR what
conversations if any has your client had
with the President or his legal team or
have you had on his behalf about a
presidential pardon I don't know I know
that mr. Cohen would never accept a
pardon from a man that he considers to
be both corrupt and a dangerous person
in the Oval Office and he is flatly
authorized me to say under no
circumstances would he accept a pardon
for mr. Trump who uses the pardon power
in a way that no president in American
history has ever used a pardon to
relieve people of guilt who committed
crimes who are
cronies of his like the sheriff in
Arizona who defied a court order was
clearly guilty and was given a pardon
Lanny for those of you for the I'm sorry
for those of you who aren't watching I
just had to pick my jaw up off the floor
for what Lanny Davis is saying and for
those of you particularly the millennial
viewers who are not familiar with Lanny
Davis Lanny Davis was the special
counsel and advisor to Bill Clinton the
president who more than anybody maybe in
American history abused his Bardon power
unjust on just one day January 20th 2001
Bill Clinton pardoned 140 people in his
final hours why did he pardoned them
because he suddenly woke up to their
innocence to their great virtue know it
was political payback for cronies that's
what he did it's onion have lanny davis
there with a straight face just sitting
there with NPR yeah it's the
presidential pardon car and you know
michael cohen would never accept a
presidential pardon i don't think that's
a worry i don't think he needs to worry
about that presidential pardon buddy
he would never accept by the way he
would accept it his spoiler alert he
would he would accept a presidential
pardon unbelievable and this is this
gets to the clinton of all of this the
fact that you have lanny davis here the
lanny davis the special counsel the
spokesman for bill clinton during his
sex scandal during those threats of
impeachment during that abuse
presidential pardons is this beautiful
divine providential moment where were
we're seeing basically 1998 in Reverse
but we're gonna talk about why that
could be a very very good thing for
president Trump and for the Republicans
the lessons to be learned there before
we get to the political ramifications
before we get to whether this is the end
of the Trump presidency or if it's only
the beginning who knows I want to bring
on a special guest who is here all the
way from Colorado we have Jack Phillips
the owner of masterpiece cake shop and
Jack Phillips we have your attorney Jim
Campbell who's here as well and the
reason that you have an attorney because
not not all cake shop owners and bakers
have to retain attorneys for years in
theirs on end is because the left and
the power the coercive power of the
state has
tried to ruin your life why is that well
it happened on this time on the very day
that the United States Supreme Court
granted our case to hear it that's right
just just for some background on yeah
you said that you didn't want to
participate in a gay wedding ceremony by
constructing a grenade yeah and so this
this case the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission president crush you they're
fighting you fight it all the way up you
actually stand pretty firm despite it
hurting your business despite all of
this it goes to the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court agrees to hear your case
and then another case comes up what is
this what is this second issue so the
very day that the Supreme Court agreed
to hear our case we got a phone call
from a lawyer in Colorado asking me to
create a custom cake it was pink on the
inside and blue on the outside to
celebrate a gender transition and while
we told this customer it would be glad
to create any other thing that we
normally do or so anything else in the
shop that was just a message with a cake
that we couldn't create and so they said
well we're gonna sue you out of
existence as they filed a complaint with
the Colorado Civil Rights Commission I
have to ask these two cases bring up a
real question are you the only Baker in
the state of Colorado how come everybody
is coming to you to bake their cakes
that you don't agree with you don't want
to participate in the ceremony because
of your religious views right no there's
another bakery actually in parking lot
across this way and another really fine
cake Chuck just across the street that
way so three of them within a block
you've got to be kidding me yeah I
actually didn't didn't know that aspect
there are multiple cakes and presumably
they would participate in a gay marriage
ceremony or whatever well one of them I
know advertises in gay magazines and gay
media so there man you must make the
best cakes in the world I have no doubt
that you do yeah there is a cake shop a
block or two away from you that
advertises in gay media and yet the
people who want you to participate in a
gay wedding or to participate in a
gender celebration whatever they go to
you instead why is that why are they
going to you I believe that it's
targeting that the state of Colorado
they know that the state of Colorado
back them up they're doubling down on us
and trying to come after us again
this is the strangest thing to I don't
really understand this because I've one
thing I've noticed is they never go to
Muslim bakers you never noticed that
they don't go to Muslim bakers they
don't go they they don't go to Orthodox
Jewish bakers they go to Christian
bakers and there seems to be this aura
of anti Christianity in the popular
culture when did that start I mean where
does that come from and why why is it
reaching such a fever pitch I don't know
but in in my case with the first case
that went to the Colorado or to the
United States Supreme Court the Supreme
Court told the Civil Rights Commission
that they were being hostile to my faith
noting that they can't do that and that
they were not treating me equal with
other bakers who gone through the same
thing with you know different cases well
it's one you have to sort of be happy
that the state of Colorado was so sloppy
in all of this I mean they made their
anti-christian bias so apparent that the
Supreme Court couldn't deny it they said
this is so clear that you have this I
have to tell you I've seen this in the
popular media read headlines about your
case many of the headlines if not most
of them are lying about the basic facts
of your case they're saying that you
refuse to serve gay customers I deal
with that every day are you the guy who
turned away the gay couple no I welcomed
I serve everybody who comes to my shop
even the two men who sued me that time
and the person who is selling me this
time I just don't create every cake with
every message if people ask me to to
create which makes perfect sense anybody
who is in any sort of creative field has
to have creative agency over what they
do people don't get to come in here and
tell me what I'm gonna do my show and
tell me what I'm gonna say they don't
get to tell dancers what sort of dance
they have to do and if they don't do the
dance they're gonna get sued out of
existence
you don't tell an actor you have to do
this role or you're gonna get sued out
of existence but the I see this I saw
this on voxcom which you know and
anytime you see a headline on voxcom
just assume the opposite just assume
whatever the opposite is and it said
that first you turned away gay customers
now you're turning away transgender
customers again I welcome everybody who
comes to my shop I don't care what their
sexual orientation is or their gender
identity is it's the message of the cake
that they asked me to create the thing I
think that's most admirable about your
entire saga which has now gone on what
six years or something is is your
cojones for lack of a better word pardon
my Spanish but pardon my french Spanish
but a lot of people I think would have
just laid down they would have said I
don't want to spend years of my life
fighting this I bake cakes I'm a small
business owner I don't want to take this
to the Supreme Court you've stood firm
despite national and international media
pressure trying to shut you down how
have you managed to do that my faith is
is strong and this time we're forced to
file a lawsuit against the state of
color hoping that that will deter them
coming after me for every whim that they
that they choose Wow that you know I
also wonder sometimes we see the left's
tactics they're so tyrannical they're so
going and they're targeting you they're
good they're saying no I'm not gonna go
to that bakery a block away I'm gonna go
to you and force you to violate your
conscience I'm gonna make you do it
you're gonna do it the right doesn't do
that you don't see an evangelical
Christian walking into a gay bakery and
saying I want you to bake me a cake that
says marriage is a solemn union between
a man and woman we never see that should
the right start adopting those tactics I
mean what is it about the political left
at this moment where they just demand
that you tow that line I don't know yeah
we're not going to toe the line that's
why we were forced into this lawsuit and
I will do the best that we can to uphold
our rights and it's so I just love the
dignity of that too which is I think
they want to make you out on in media as
being this there's a Nazi basically I
mean you know everyone who's slightly to
the right of Vladimir Lenin now is a
Nazi that's what they all say and and
but you're just so simply spoken about
these are these are my views this is my
faith I'm not going to violate it this
is what I do and I'm not going to lay
down for you
did you see this this I know I know you
didn't cuz nobody watches the Jimmy
Kimmel show but maybe you saw a clip of
it afterward Jimmy Kimmel did a whole
segment on you about how what a terrible
guy you are I haven't seen a reference
to it so I really can't comment on it
well the the whole premise of the clip
he's you know he's doing his thing which
is to almost tell a joke but then make a
political statement and then his
audience doesn't laugh but they clap
that's kind of their new cheat but but
his whole premise is that you you hate
gay people
you know you hate transgender people and
and the reason is because you are gay
because you are in a creative profession
so that makes you gay and I'm always
amazed by this turn from the lefties
which is there's there's nothing more
wonderful than gay culture we all have
to embrace and participate in every
aspect and every changing aspect of gay
culture and if you don't you're gay and
that's an insult hahaha that's an insult
it doesn't it seems so contradictory do
you do you have hope for religious
freedom in America moving forward you
got this win at the court what do you
think 1020 years down the line the
Supreme Court ruled like I said that the
Commission was hostile to my faith and I
can't do that in the United States
Supreme Court upheld religious freedom I
think really clearly on this and so I
have a lot of hope for it a lot of
support people coming in and yeah it
gives me hope that and because your case
gives me hope too
you've become a sort of central figure
in these elections probably unwittingly
it's not like you're running for federal
office or something but you've
demonstrated the power of the courts and
how much the left has perverted the
courts over so many years and you've
made these federal judgeships a major
issue in these elections do you do you
think that that will be a major issue in
2018 2020 I think it should be the
courts is there's a lot of power in the
courts and I'm glad to see that they
roll correctly this time yeah
[Music]
once this is all said and done you'll
you'll have been tied up in court so far
six years and there's no end in sight
they're gonna keep going after you
what does your business look like after
the left has tried to gut every aspect
of oh the Commission did require me to
start making cakes for same-sex weddings
a few years ago but rather than do that
since I'm in the wedding business we had
to give up our wedding business which is
40 percent of our income at the time so
I had 10 employees it was down to 4
right now with the news it's it's crazy
and we're really busy but a year from
now won't see how that pans out but they
did take away a good deal of our income
it's unbelievable I mean it was such a
targeting they say you can't participate
in weddings anymore sorry is there do
you only do local work how can people
support you I know that look I know it
myself I read the headlines and I think
how can I support this guy
how can people go out there and support
your legal cause support your business
you gave me a shirt I don't have the
shirt on it's the shirt that you're
wearing I can't wait to wear that around
La I'm gonna get Tomatoes thrown at me
but it's such a great statement for a
great company how can people help you
out well we have shirts and mugs and
when things calm down we ship brownies
and cookies that's helpful but yeah
prayer for us and supporting the
Alliance defending freedom the attorneys
that are representing us that's always
good too because they're not just
fighting for me they're fighting for all
of us that's right I love ADF I do
before I let you guys go I do want to
talk a little bit just about the legal
work that you guys have been doing you
do great legal work in defense of
religious liberty in in many cases but
obviously this one's been going on for
six years what what's your view on the
future of religious liberty and why is
it so under attack today
well we're optimistic I mean what we've
seen is the recent win in Jack's case
and the recent win in Jack's case made
it clear that the government can't be
hostile to people of faith we also won
other cases last term that made it clear
that the government can't force for
instance pro-life pregnancy centers to
speak messages that are against their
conscience so we think that the court is
on a hot streak in protecting not only
freedom of speech but also freedom of
religion and we think that that can only
we're hopeful that will only continue
that's right because I think a lot of
lefties I talked to a lot of lefties I'm
from New York I live in LA you know and
they
gently believed that religious freedom
is just a euphemism for bigotry and
animus they rely actually think they
earnestly believe that I don't think
that's an excuse and it's because they
don't take religion seriously and they
don't understand that other people do
take religion seriously this Court has
been terrific on the issue of religious
liberty that's why the left is going
after it so badly it's why they're
trying to stop Brett Kavanaugh as
nomination but but this case is shown
that that's not inevitable that's not or
there are other cases around the country
where we can look around and just see
like oh yes religious freedom is making
a comeback well I think one thing I'd
specifically point to the case we just
went in Jack's regarding Jack's decision
with the Colorado agency said there was
they compared Jack's beliefs to bigotry
and so that's the exact talking point
you just referenced and when the court
looked at it they said that kind of a
statement from a government official
that in and of itself is problematic so
what it's basically done is taken the
left talking point on religious freedom
this religious freedom is just code for
bigotry and they've said the government
has no business saying that has no
business taking that position it has no
business marginalizing people of faith
so I think that's a very important thing
to emphasize that's great that is a
great point you it's always a good
political line it's always helpful
politically when you can use your
opponent's words to twist them into
pretzels and they're they're so good at
doing it that you couldn't have asked
you know for a better opponent in that
way but it's really wonderful I really
appreciate you guys and God bless good
luck and all the rest I hope you keep
getting victories because it's not just
a victory for masterpiece cake shop it's
a victory for every American who
appreciates religious liberty thanks so
much for being here desi I'll let you go
I know you've got you've got important
work to talk about and I've got to talk
about the political circus before before
we get to all of this we're gonna talk
about the political ramifications of all
of the news out today we're also going
to talk about how CNN doesn't have any
views we're talk about this Molly
Tibbets case why for example it's fallen
out of the news gee I wonder and I do
want to get to this day in history and
actually say a few nice words about Bill
Clinton before I can do that I have got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
if you go over to daily wire calm thank
you you help us keep the lights on you
keep the leftist tears filling up my cup
a day-by-day you get me you get the end
replevin show the ben shapiro show ask
questions in the mailbag ask questions
in the conversation ben shapiro is
coming up next none of that matters
because right now we have the leftist
tears tumblr and when we get judge
Kavanagh confirmed and we keep expanding
religious liberty throughout this
country and when we keep getting to bake
the cakes we want to bake and eat the
cakes we want to eat and live in this
beautiful land of freedom this is gonna
fill up which is good because leftist
ears are actually better even than whole
milk when you're eating a nice slice of
religious freedom cake go to daily wire
calm get your leftist ears tumblr we'll
be right back
okay what are the political
ramifications of all of this you know we
couldn't get away from Michael Cohen and
Paul manna for that easily what are the
political ramifications well it doesn't
look great in the short term does it
especially if you're watching CNN you've
got a real case now for impeachment not
that the Democrats needed it they were
running on impeachment anyway long
before this but you've got sort of
almost the beginnings of a legal case
they're gonna be all focused on this
it's gonna drown it out in the media
let's look at one of the preeminent
lefties one of the most famous lefties
in the world for the past many decades
and get to see what he thinks about it
mister professor Chomsky take it away
take say the huge issue of the
interference and pristine elections that
did the Russians interfere in our
elections an issue of overwhelming
concern that the media I mean in most of
the world that's almost a joke first of
all if you're interested in foreign
interference in our elections
whatever the Russians may have done
barely counts ways in the balance as
compared with what another state does
openly brazenly and with the enormous
support he's talking about Israel there
because he doesn't like Israel very much
but he makes a salient point which is
that the throughout the rest of the
world this is considered a joke for some
obvious reasons which is that
everybody's always trying to interfere
in everybody's elections and for the
other reason that this issue of Russian
alleged interference doesn't really
affect our lives at all doesn't affect
American politics doesn't probably
didn't affect the election in any way in
so much as it affected the election it's
because it convinced Americans not to
vote for the Democrat because it exposed
just how awful the Democrats are so do
people care is Professor Chomsky right
well he's only right about a few things
in this world but this happens to be one
of them all of the polling shows that
nobody cares about this all of the
polling not just by right-wing firms but
people ranked this basically dead last
on their questions of public policy and
public affairs
doesn't matter consider CNN CNN covers
the the Russia non scandal I think about
twenty five hours a day roughly eight
days per week and year-over-year CNN's
viewership is down twenty four percent
total day and it's down 23 percent in
primetime year-over-year this week over
this week last year nobody watches this
actually and there's some great
statistics at the Discovery Channel and
the History Channel both do better in
primetime than CNN news does the cable
news network the Clinton news network
Nickelodeon and Investigation Discovery
do better all day Nickelodeon does
better all day than the cable news
network
so the question then is could this hurt
Trump anyway even if we don't care we
don't watch it the Russia thing is not a
big issue could it hurt Trump his
administration politically legally yeah
of course it could of course it could
anything can happen in politics MP I had
a lot of lefties some old friends
writing to me yesterday they say haha
yes you're gonna take down Trump this
must be a really bad day for you huh
and I thought there were two scenarios
here there are two ways this turns out
the best-case scenario is the president
Trump survives this scandal just like he
survives every other scandal where they
said they're gonna get Trump that's the
best-case scenario the absolute
worst-case scenario is that he is Ramu
impeached and removed from office and
then we get president pence ha ha ha ha
then we're gonna get as many cakes as we
want ha ha and a lot of religious
freedom and a conservative president
that's the worst case scenario that's a
pretty good worst-case scenario and by
the way he's not going to be removed
from office it's it's virtually
impossible that he's removed from office
certainly in the short term in the long
term who knows in the long term anything
could happen
but how would this hurt Trump let's look
at a few lessons of history one one way
to compare this is the John Edwards
scandal she remember John Edwards he's
the most just generic bland Democrat
ever to run for office I think he's made
of like putty or clay and he's got just
got that perfectly quaffed hair and that
hair became a big issue in the election
because it is expensive haircuts
one of the bits of evidence that he was
funneling campaign money to pay off a
mistress so he ran he ran for president
in 2008 in the case of John Edwards this
came to light finally in 2012 he was
brought to trial for it the case of
Edwards is much worse he he spent well
over a million dollars funneling money
to his mistress to cover all of this up
during the campaign President Trump is
accused of funneling a few hundred
thousand dollars which I think President
Trump like that's what he pays for
breakfast I think he goes down to Trump
Tower the more throws like few hundred
thousand dollars down there so it's a
matter of dollars dollars and cents
Edwards was worse Edwards got indicted
in that case on six felony counts and he
got off
he completely got off indicted on six
felony counts was found not guilty on
one count and a mistrial was declared on
all of the others so even Edwards got
off it is much much harder to get the
sitting president of the United States
than it is to get an ex senator it's
much harder in even John Edwards one of
the least sympathetic figures of
American politics even that guy got off
on every count on every single count
years after he was in office and he was
just a lowly senator now how does Donald
Trump how does this really affect him
the Democrats are gonna run on
impeachment let's say that the Democrats
win the house which historically
speaking they should win the house but
because everything's going very very
well because the Trump administration
has governed in a terrific manner if
they do win the house then they need a
simple majority to impeach and maybe
they'll do that although you kind of
wonder some of those red state Democrats
they might not be so eager to impeach
but they're saying that they're eager to
impeach and let's say they do it when
you get to the Senate you need 67 votes
to convict in the Senate is that going
to happen is anybody predicting that the
Democrats are gonna win 67 seats in the
Senate does anybody really predicting
that the Democrats are gonna win the
Senate I don't know I suppose it's
possible but they're not going to win 67
see it sure doesn't look like him so at
least not in 2018 so you need 67 to
convict is that going to happen probably
not so here's where the
news comes in all of this might redound
to president Trump's benefit I know this
seems insane that now you've got Cohen
you've got the drama you've got Cohen it
pleads guilty and mana for dat mana and
then drama drama okay
well I'm old enough to remember 1998 I'm
old enough to remember politics in the
90s I I was born in 1990 and yet I was
such a political fiend as a
five-year-old I was paying attention to
all of these things I was I remember
George HW Bush I remember you know my
grandpa would teach me read my lips no
new taxes and then Bush raised taxes of
course
and I remember campaigning in my
first-rate classroom for Bob Dole I
remember clearly all of the Clinton
scandals all of the Clinton impeachment
I really couldn't stand Bill Clinton and
neither could the entire Republican
Party but there are so many lessons to
get out of that back Clinton scandal
because you got to remember there were
investigations going back to 94 96 98
they never got Clinton they never got
Clinton it seemed like a little bit of
an overreach I do I do want to get to
that in a second I want to get to this
day in history what we can learn from
him before that though let's just clear
up a little bit of news because this is
this is too much not to talk about have
you heard about Molly Tippett's Miley
Tibbets that poor girl who college
students she went she went missing they
just found her body this was major news
for weeks and weeks it was when they
found this poor girl's body it was the
biggest news story on Google News Apple
news and then they found out who the
killer was they thought he's the killer
the boyfriend or this or a local with
this or that they found out the killer
is an illegal alien he was the guy who
led them to the body and he's now you
know the main suspect this is how Cable
News reacted the Republican Party is
actually not working on behalf of the
American people they are working on
behalf of Donald Trump and he's been
able to bully them into their silence
and I don't think that today changes
much unfortunately I'm sure we'll hear
what he has to say about this at his his
rally but Fox News is talking about you
know a
in Iowa and not this right and tomorrow
morning we know he'll wake up and tweet
and sort of you know
smirch the reputation of Michael Cohen
and all the people around him a girl in
Iowa a girl in Iowa and Fox News right
they're the only ones talking about
Molly Tibbets oh no it was every single
news agency in the country and and and
internationally was talking about this
missing girl was talking about Molly Tim
it's all of these channels NBC CBS The
Associated Press Google News Apple News
everybody was talking about it until it
became clear that the killer is an
illegal alien and then the only person
talking about it was was Fox News then
the only outlet talking about it was Fox
News so Rees trying to use this as an
example of Fox News being dishonest Fox
News is the only honest cable news
network is the only honest one of the
whole bunch just some girl and I why
were you talking about her before oh
because it was it's a compelling story
and this poor girl got murdered but it
now it cuts against your political
narrative because an illegal alien is
the one who did it look at CBS ran the
headline said GOP seizing Molly Tibbets
murder as political issue
we're not seizing it as a political
issue it's been a major news story for a
long time now we're just following it to
its logical conclusion and you're all
abandoning it as a political issue it's
the Democrats are always projecting they
found out it said christiana by Hina
Rivera twenty-four-year-old illegal
alien the CNN coverage this morning of
the killer
they found the killer they bring him in
CNN coverage doesn't even acknowledge
that he's an illegal alien listen to
chief liya Wafaa being asked about this
on CNN on the Clinton news network
listen to how she spends it but bail I
want to get one last question sure
because it is a story a very important
story in the news it has to do with
Molly Tibbets the young woman in Iowa
who was murdered her body believed to be
found yesterday a person has been
charged with that this person is an
undocumented immigrant Mike Pence and
the president have suggested the
immigration laws need to be stronger so
that people like this man who was
accused of this murder were not in the
country your reaction you know my I'm so
sorry for the family here and I know
this is hard not only for the family but
for the people in her community the
people throughout Iowa
oh but one of the things we have to
remember is we need an immigration
system that is effective that focuses on
where real problems are last month I
went down to the border and I saw where
children we've heard about we've heard
enough from Lyle Wafaa
did you catch that in there yeah you
might have missed it cuz she's gotten
really good at hiding it she said oh
this must be so hard oh this must be
really tough for the family oh my heart
goes out to the family but due to dinner
dinner dinner dinner - she actually
shortened her but it was but because she
didn't want us to hear it you know but
butts negates sentences in politics
that's how politics works say oh I look
I really really don't want to raise your
taxes I really look raising taxes is
terrible I don't want to raise taxes but
we're gonna raise your taxes a lot look
I you I know you want to keep your
doctor you really want it but you're
you'll totally get to keep your doctor
but no do you want it's an outrage it's
an outrage for this there's a woman Lyle
go is out on there she's got her talking
points she wants it yeah it's really
terrible that this illegal alien killed
this girl but we shouldn't have any
immigration reform is that she's saying
we need immigration reform no you don't
want it we're trying to reform
immigration we want to enforce the laws
and get people out of the country who
shouldn't be in the country get criminal
aliens out of the country
Liz Warren doesn't want any of that
she's campaigning against that pretty
vociferously but this is a real issue I
think people like Liz Warren like Lyle
Wafaa they don't realize that like
illegal alien crime has a real effect on
people and in many states illegal aliens
are much much more likely to commit
crimes to be members of gangs to bring
Drugs and Crime over president Trump was
exactly right we pointed that out and I
think she just denies it cuz she doesn't
see it she doesn't see even the effect
on the welfare system immigrant led
households legal and illegal in
certainly illegal aliens access public
services they can access public services
immigrant led households are much more
likely to be on welfare some form of
welfare and we'll talk about a welfare
with regard to President Clinton and
President Trump in a second there
they're more likely to be on it she
doesn't she doesn't matter - Liz Warren
who cares less Warren's a rich Native
American lady you know she's a real
rich white native-american lady and so
it doesn't affect her but it does affect
people who pay taxes it does affect
people who are you know who are relying
on smaller amounts of income or have
slower margins than Liz Warren who care
about the future fiscal solvency of the
country Liz Warren is a lady of a
certain age and a more young younger
generations are gonna have to deal with
fiscal insolvency we're gonna have to
deal with the entitlement state these
things have effects that she isn't
noticing and they just spin it and spin
it who cares if it works in reality does
it work in practice does it work in or
doesn't work in theory rather that's
what they're all saying and it's it's
ridiculous it won't it won't serve them
well in the the 2018 or 2020 elections
and this brings us to the real election
question which is this day in history
then I'll let you go but we do have to
finish this up because this is the big
takeaway I think for Republicans you
know I agree with Ben's analysis almost
entirely on how this looks legally and
how this looks politically but I'm much
more hopeful I think because because it
worked out very well for Bill Clinton
because there doesn't seem that the
threat of this taking down Trump is that
high if you look at Edwards if you look
at Clinton I get it there's a hypocrisy
all around but I don't think they can
get him 1996 on this day in history
providential perhaps Bill Clinton signs
the personal responsibility and work
opportunity Act this is after he
campaigned on and on and on he said we
must end welfare as we have come to know
it Milwaukee this was the you know he
was constantly repeating this it drove a
number of his Democrat allies and nuts
we must end welfare as we've come to
know it and the President Clinton's
welfare reform was an excellent law and
it worked it kills me to complement the
Clintons but this was really good it
made immigrants ineligible for welfare
for five years it posed a lifetime ban
on food stamps for drug felons and in it
reformed the welfare system it got
people off the rolls The effect of this
was it saved the federal government a
lot of money in the caseload fell by 60%
60% of people got off of welfare because
of welfare reform turns out they didn't
need it the economy was doing very well
there were so many there were soon
the similarities between right now and
the mid-to-late 90s that it it's one of
these moments where you kind of wonder
if the good Lord is like you know
sometimes the good Lord whispers to us
this is Michael Michael che attention
and then other times he's like you a
stupid idiots why aren't you paying
attention do you know he's smacking us
in the face I think this might be one of
them I think a Lanny Davis is the key to
that yeah first of all this is about
Clintons because it's trying to undo the
2016 election where the Clintons lost
and then you've got the Clintons lawyer
now on exactly the other side doing
exactly the other things what does this
tell us in 1994 you had the
investigations beginning into Bill
Clinton's sexual degeneracy so you had
them you know they're investigating a
Paula Jones sexual harassment then all
of a sudden you've got investigations
over Monica Lewinsky special counsel is
appointed can store or independent
counsel rather it becomes this
wide-ranging investigation it's covering
travelgate it's covering whitewater it's
covering the sex stuff it's covering all
of these things a lot of similarities to
how wide-ranging other Special Counsel
investigations can be then you had a the
president lying now there's an
allegation that President Trump has lied
but at least he hasn't lied under oath
Bill Clinton it was much worse because
he lied under oath and he still got off
though Clinton still got off even lying
under oath because it was a step too far
the American people didn't want
President Clinton impeached what's the
evidence of that well in the 1998
election when impeachment is hot on the
table it's under way the investigations
are going on Newt Gingrich was positive
that this was going to get the GOP 30
seats in the house what happened
the GOP lost seats in the House in the
Senate Gingrich had to resign he was he
was so shocked and ashamed that it had
exactly the negative effect in in 2000
same thing Gingrich or rather the GOP
lost seats and both the House and the
Senate we eked out the election down in
Florida thank you that the hanging chads
but we lost seats in the House in the
Senate elections it hurt Bill Clinton
legally in the headlines or whatever but
it
helped him politically in the long run
because people don't want the president
impeached with all of this drama people
say Donald Trump stop tweeting stop
creating drama stop creating drama the
whole reason we elected the guy is for
drama are you not entertained as this
not why you were here that we elected
this guy for drama because if to serve
policy purposes by the way it because
when people get along go along to get
along and they're really nice things
don't get done when people are dramatic
things get done we've seen a lot of
great stuff come out of this presidency
the drama I think is helpful here
because when when people look at this
are they looking at and saying Michael
Cohen and this fraud and this and he
talked to him and up but that but uh
know what they're saying and all of the
public policy or all of the public
polling shows this is we don't care
about Russia stop why are you talking
about Russia why what is Bob Muller
doing why is oat rump had sex with porn
stars yeah he's bragged about that of
course he had sex with porn stars the
economy is doing well we have peace
abroad we have families united in Korea
we have hostages coming back from Korea
we've got our allies pitching into NATO
we've got better trade deals being
negotiated we have a record high
employment record low joblessness the
economy is doing better than ever
why the hell are you talking to me about
Russia and porn stars what are you doing
I think that is what people are seeing
and I think there was a similar effect
in in the 90s Republicans got it so
wrong the the evidence of that is the
polls they were certain this would help
them they were certain it was going to
clinch elections for them and they lost
they lost elections looks very similar
to today the Democrats are certain
they've got him this is it Oh baby house
here we come Senate here we come
2020 here we come we've got the same
players we got the same country we got
the same people I will Donald Trump
survive you know he's a fighter he's
more of a political fighter than a lot
of politicians we've seen recently and
if history is showing us anything if
past is precedent here it I would put my
money on Donald Trump worst case
scenario we get president Pence not the
worst thing in the world but I would put
my money on President Trump
there's a lot to hope for they're gonna
make this all about Michael Cohen
they're gonna make this all about Paul
Manafort but I think it is a lot of
noise it's gonna be kind of painful it's
gonna be kind of awkward it's gonna be
legally troublesome it's gonna be
politically worrisome but if I had to
put money down I would put I would still
put money down on us surviving this
Thank You President Clinton all right
that's our show
I've got to get out of here I'm sure
we'll have another 50,000 news stories
that we have to cover today so I'll
probably go late tomorrow too
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you